la sala de espera de este hospital de
budapest está casi llena todos llegaron
a recibir la primera dosis de la vacuna
sputnik bay
hungría se convirtió en el primer
miembro de la unión europea en utilizar
la vacuna rusa el sueño web que la gente
viene de ocho distritos diferentes de
budapest vacunaremos a 990 personas en
dos días este es un buen número y si
continúa así en todo el país será un muy
buen resultado para los húngaros tenían
que esperar la aprobación de las
autoridades europeas para usar esta
vacuna pero el presidente de viktor
orbán prefirió tomar la iniciativa
durante mucho tiempo el mandatario ha
criticado la lentitud del proceso de
validación y compra de vacunas por parte
de bruselas
hungría ya ha ordenado dos millones de
dosis para vacunar a un millón de
personas las autoridades también
comprarán vacunas chinas por si no hemos
llegado a un acuerdo consigo farc la
primera entrega debería llegar la semana
que viene por lo tanto estarán
disponibles 500.000 dosis de la vacuna
china
la vacuna sputnik bet tiene una eficacia
de más del 91 por ciento la unión
europea celebró la noticia pero sin
acelerar su validación por parte de la
agencia europea de medicamentos por su
parte serbia y austria se han ofrecido
como voluntarios para producir la vacuna
rusa y distribuirla en europa si fuera
validada